viele männer wenig frauen ziemlich voll
klingt nach disco ist aber der neue
bundestag
ich habe mir den ersten schultag der
abgeordneten mal an
jetzt haben wir ein größeres parlament
als indien
das ist schwierig und ich glaube dass
ich mit ja
vielen dank na wie geht's was ich noch
habe ich ja dass nico meckel wie immer
alles wäre es nicht sinnvoller male
obergrenze für abgeordnete zu machen als
für flüchtlinge von mir auch 200.000
derzeit werden sie doch so geil oder der
neue bundestag ist ja der männlichste
bundestag seit langem
würden sie sich für die frauenquote
umoperieren lassen um operieren müsste
ich mich nicht lassen weil in unserer
fraktion wir haben ja 40 prozent fahren
das ist ja eher die hfg und die cdu und
die csu dabei problemen auch eine
einzelne op würde ja die gesamtquote
verbessern karl lauterbach glaub ich
brauche das nicht also ich denke beide
geschlechter habt weil sie hinten zu
viele manager nicht weiter aber bei
frauen meistens intelligenter sind als
männer gegenseitig in die fdp ja deshalb
so prima zdf weil sich alle
intelligenter sind als männer
ja das ist richtig und warum wir nicht
an da war ich mir jetzt auch der
intendant beispielsweise andere frau
heute schon wieder auf von der frau
bekam nur vorwerk zudem ist ja quasi
erster schultag die abgeordneten
konvents haus ja so ist es meine
schultüte ja schon gepackt oder sind das
schon auf die kisten die hier jetzt
heute von mottenkiste
aber sie haben ja gesagt jetzt wird
ausgemistet aufgeräumt könnte man nicht
mit der afg anfangen
nein überhaupt nicht hier wollen wir mit
den altparteien aufräumen
und deren politik
sie müssen jetzt tage wieder stellen ach
so ich dachte werden irgendwas
inhaltliches noch zu sagen
was ich ja kurios fand ist dass die afg
die ersten waren die irgendwie
angemeldet haben dass ihnen die räume zu
klein sind finde ich ziemlich bonzen
partei mäßig also als ich hier
eingezogen bin 2009 waren wir drei
monate mit vier leuten in so einem raum
das war auch stressig wären sie denn
bereit theoretisch ihr büro mit einem
mal therapeuten zu teilen wenn es sich
vermeiden lässt würde ich es gerne
vermeiden
aber wenn sie alexander gauland zum
beispiel aufnehmen würden hätte das
ganze auch noch so ein pflegerischen
aspekt ja weiß ich nicht wann sie stehen
sonst sonst muss ich sie jagen
wie war der erste schultag war
sicherlich ein bisschen auch mit
neugierde gesetzt aber letztlich war es
auch ein spannender tag und ich glaube
dass es gelingen wird dass wir ganz
schnell integrierter teil dieses
parlaments
also hier im deutschen bundestag sind
sie jetzt für integration aber wenn es
um flüchtlinge geht nicht so oder so ist
jetzt ein weites feld
da ich weiß auch nicht wie man also die
integration in die politik betrieb ist
und zusammen ist auch einfacher und
schöner als flüchtlinge zu integrieren
also ich glaube wir sollten das auch die
geschäftsgrundlage verständigt wie wir
hier mit der richtigen politik streiten
wollen dann lassen sich die parlamente
ok eine frage noch nie
ich wollte ja abschiede minister werden
tatsächlich hält es das ministerium mal
bald gibt ja die migrations ministerium
dann will ich ein bisschen relegation
delegations ministerium und dann wird
abgeschrieben und haken sie eigentlich
wirklich das klingt die indikation ja
plötzlich gut an
klicken sie auf das muss
das haben jetzt gesagt aber schon der
erste schultag ist vorüber die
abgeordneten mussten direkt zwei stunden
nachsitzen
da gab es lange gesichter sie sind jetzt
froh dass sie nach hause dürfen ans
buffet mal sehen was mutti gekocht hat
und damit zurück ins studio